і відверто вам скажу я розглядаю
найбільшеми своїми союзниками саме
освітян тому що розраховую що освітяни
ее розбираються в цьому предметі справді
професійно і для нас надзвичайно важливо
аби освітяни також були носіями реформи
могли пояснити суспільству журналістам в
чому полягає насправді реформа якщо це
означи однією фразою полягає в тому що
нам треба перейти від нашої традиційної
школи яка концентрується пересічно на
сумі знань Тобто ми транслюємо дітям
знання а вони повинні ті знання потім
відтворити відтворити на потім
відтворити на тестуванні яке теж є
цілком знанневе і криза сучасної школи
полягає в тому власне що знання тепер
страшенно
примножуються зростають і школа
перестала бути основним місцем де дають
знання
Отже зважаючи на те що ми живемо в
інформаційну добу і зважаючи на те що ми
з вами взагалі не можемо
передбачити яких умовах технологічних І
взагалі суспільних будуть ці діти які
сьогодні вчаться в нашій школі будувати
свою професійну кар'єру через 10 років
от згадайте що технологічно було в
нашому розпорядженні наприклад ще 10
років
тому сьогодні зараз кожен має мобільний
телефон А що було 10 років тому тобто як
будуть розвиватись технології ще через
10 років і до чого мають адаптуватись
наші діти Ми не можемо спрогнозувати
тому ми їм маємо дати сьогодні крім
знань
ще деякі інші дуже важливі компоненти і
ці компоненти - це вміння застосовувати
ці знання для вирішення власних проблем
і професійних завдань
це уміння зорієнтуватися в величезному
потоці інформації А для цього потрібна
ціннісна платформа тобто цінності і
ставлення які вони можуть виробляти і
також м'які навички які потрібні людині
впродовж всього життя щоб вчитися і
ее вміти відповідати на нові виклики як
таку школу взагалі будувати тобто від
школи знай до школи компетентності
по-перше давайте Розберемося що таке
компетентності Цей курс живе своїм
життям Тобто я переключаю на це він іде
далі Я перепрошую якась технічна прознач
по-перше з чого складається така
школа основні чотири компоненти Це новий
зміст освіти це вчителі які володіють
компете методиками компетентнісного
навчання це новий підхід до управління в
освіті і сучасне освітнє
середовище Ми мусимо будувати це все вже
починати зараз ми не можемо чекати Бо
коли ми кажемо що з 2018 року почнеться
перший клас нової української школи за
новими компетентнісними стандартами Ми
не даємо відповідь А що робити цим дітям
які сьогодні навчаються в школах так Я
стверджую абсолютно впевнено що в нас є
ціла низка шкіл в Україні які вже є
школами компетентностей і я тут бачу
керівників таких шкіл серед
аудиторії але ми працюємо на
пересічного вчителя на пересічну школу
тобто для наша наша мета щоб реформою
міг скористатися кожен український
школяр і кожен український школяр відчув
підвищення якості освіти а цеє задача
значно масштабніша І тому ми зараз
запустили оновлення
програм не чекаючи 2018 року принаймні в
межах того стандарту який ми зараз маємо
ми вже зараз почали працювати над
оновленням нового освітнього середовища
особливо в сільських територіях місто
Київ теж робить дуже багато в зв'язку з
фінансовою
децентралізацією зараз місцеві бюджети
виросли ну в одних громада сім раз а в
такому
е мегаполісі як місто Київ скільки раз
вас виріс бюджет в нас виросло в шість
разів а деякі показники Лілі Михайлівна
наприклад це дрібв'язок який ми надали
освіттянам цього року в 10 разів
тому є потенціал і важливо щоби місцеві
ради використовували його саме для
освіти а вони можуть і мають це робити
тому що в нас з вами є план ми показуємо
куди ми хочемо прийти є зрозуміло під що
мають даватися
гроші для того щоб ми всі говорили ними
термінами давайте узгодимо що таке
компетентності тому що для нас одні
говорять що це зовсім не нове слово але
при тому плутають компетенції і
компетентності інші говорять про те що в
нас значить в словниках є дуже різні
визначення щодо компетентності коли ми
говоримо про українську нову українську
школу і цю реформу ми користуємося
визначеннями які узгоджені радою Європою
і які чітко виписані в рекомендаціях
Європейського парламенту та Ради Європи
щодо формування ключових компетентностей
освіти впродовж
життя тобто для того щоб ми розуміли
одне одного треба чітко узгодити
термінологію що таке компетентності
згідно з цим визначенням Яке
загальноприйняте зараз в усіх освітніх
системах сучасних освітніх систем
компетентності мають фактично чотири
складові це це знання я підкреслюю
знання тому що без ядра знань ви не
можете формувати уміння тому що є такі
видатні політики які розказують що тепер
в нас знань в школах не буде це є брехня
і чергові міф Отже компетентності
складається знань
умінь але ці уміння не є абстрактними
якимись уміннями а уміння скористатися
цим ми знаннями а також пошукати від
цього ядра знань потрібні споріднені
знання щоби використовувати це для
вирішення власних і професійних
завдань далі цінності ціннісна
платформа з точки зору якої людина може
сприймати інформацію і формувати своє
ставлення до тієї чи іншої ситуації отже
все це разом ця комбінація визначає
здатність особи успішно вирішувати
життєві проблеми провадити професійну і
подальшу навчальну діяльність ось От
коли ми говоримо про слова
компетентність це ми маємо на
увазі в концепції в законі визначено
поки що перелік 10ти ключових
компетентностей він є дуже динамічним і
це ми сьогодні говоримо що потрібне
нашим дітям ми побачимо цей перелік може
глядатися і багато освітніх систем
працюють над переглядом своїх переліків
ви бачите тут 10 компетентностей два
стовпчики і є один стовпчик який е-е
чомусь там не видно п'ятоні На
привеликий жаль але це нещо інакше як
інформаційно-комунікаційна цифрова
компетентність так от перший стовпчик
спілкування мовами рідною державною
іноземними математична грамотність
компетентності в природничих науках
технологіях інформаційноф Інформаційна
компетентність чи цифрова от вони в
принципі сьогодні в наших школах
присутні не завжди у вигляді компетент
ностей в тому розумінні яке ми що
розібрали але принаймні ми на це
працюємо даємо знання формуємо
уміння що ж якщо ми глянемо от на той
наступний
стовбчик це є та прогалина в сучасній
системі освіти яка відносить і відкидає
нас назад від того куди рухається
суспільство і плин часу у XX столітті це
уміння вчитись впродовж життя соціальні
громадянські компетентності
підприємливість і фінансова грамотність
загальнокультурна грамотність екологічна
грамотність і здорове життя при цьому я
наголошую що ми в Україні маємо точки
росту і школи які сьогодні запроваджують
ці компетентності в рамках власних
авторських програм власного освітнього
середовища власних методик роботи з
дітьми але це не стало зараз практикою А
нам потрібно щоб це стало практикою у
кожній українській школи
є крім компетентностей так звані
наскрізні ЗМІ вміння які не прив'язані
до якихось галузей чи предметів А які в
ціло лому потрібні сучасні
люди критичне мислення тут все зрозуміло
Так є проблема владі важ працювати з
громадянами які мають вивинене критичне
мис Тому це може не всім подобатися Але
я думаю що українське суспільство вже
переросло цю фазу і мусить змиритися
весь політичний естеблішмент з тим що
українські громадяни завоювали собі
право критично мислити і ми маємо цьому
вчити наших дітей Ми маємо їх вчити не
просто читати а розуміти про читане і
його критично аналізувати висловлювати й
аргументувати свою позицію і думку
співпрацювати в команді тому що зараз
тільки команди індивідуально людина може
робити Продукти є звичайно блискучі
особистості генії і так далі але
оскільки дуже
багато
праці в технологічній сфері будуть
виконувати машини це неуникненно ви
бачите скільки функції вже забирає в
людини комп'ютер і комп'ютерні
автоматизовані систе але є речі які не
може зробити машина і от саме на
розвиток цього треба спрямувати освітній
процес у кожної дитини і вміння
співпрацювати й будувати команди
співпрацювати і комунікувати з іншими
людьми заради досягнення результату - це
дуже важливе уміння уміння застосовувати
емоційний інтелект послухайте ми про
емоційний інтелект в наших школах
взагалі не говоримо Ми починаємо шести
років працювати на розвиток аналітичних
здідбностей
дітей але аналітичних з точки зору
запам'ятовування відтворення інформації
от в чому проблема а не з точки зору
критичного переосмислення інформації і
ее оцінювати ризики приймати рішення
конструктивно керувати
емоціями здатність логічно
обґрунтовувати свою позицію творити
творити тому що процес творення
це є одна з функцій абсолютно
притаманних саме для людини і людського
е вої
сутності уміння вирішувати проблеми
зрозуміло Отже на скрізні вміння ви
бачили Це в концепції Це трошки теорії
Вибачте що я собі дозволила її повторити
Але це мені здається на такому
початковому входженні для нас дуже
важливо щоб ми могли доносити це до
інших людей
е-е
тепер взагалі по сперейняттю реформи
освіти 70
ість майже відсотків
українців абсолютно жорстко кажуть що
реформувати освіту треба і всі
відчувають що вона відстає від потреб
дітей сьогодні серед наших учителів 90%
вважають що треба реформувати правда
кожен розуміє під цим щось інше в чому
полягає реформа Тому так важливо її
узгодити з освітянами і
суспільством на що взагалі працює
система освіти на самореалізацію
особистості і
її внесок у розвиток суспільства Тому ми
маємо спроектувати що потрібно цій
особистості буде наприклад у
2020 А взагалі наші дітки які зараз
навчаються в початковій школі для них ще
на більшу перспективу роках от на
світовому економічному форумі були
сформульовані основні навички які будуть
потрібні Для успішного
працевлаштування подивіться що там є
уміння вирішувати складні завдання
критичне мислення креативність
управління людьми навички координації
взаємодії емоційний інтелект судження і
прийняття рішень клієнтоорієнтованість
уміння вести переговори і когнітивна
дучкість що з того ми вчимо в наших
школах А потім нам роботодавці кажуть
слухайте Ми змушені ні формувати
паралельну систему освіти власне для
того щоб мати кваліфіковані кадри або
брати на провідні позиції управлінські
людей які отримали закордонну
освіту розумієте Ми живемо міфами про ту
нашу найкращу радянську освіту Тільки
треба пам'ятати що та Радянська освіта
була добра для того радянського
суспільства А сьогодні ми живемо в інший
час
технологічно ідеологічно і в самостійній
країні
і
тепер я сказала про те що 2018 рік - це
перший клас давайте подивимося з точки
зору цього на наступний навчальний рік
тому що це буде рік пілотування Бо перед
тим як щось віддати на всю Україну Ми
повинні відпілотувати в пілотних школах
А це новий стандарт початкової школи які
особливості цього стандарту КР крім того
що він орієнтований на формування
компетентностей крім того що він буде
виписаний в результатах навчання і
вчителі отримують свободу формувати свої
освітні програми ми запропонуємо типові
освітні програми одна освітня програма
буде з максимальною інтеграцією Хто з
вас вивчав досвід Фінляндії Канади інших
провідних освітніх систем розуміє що я
говорю коли дітей в початковій про що я
говорю коли дітей в початковій школі
навчають через теми і одна насрізна тема
іде через усі
уроки Немає предметного чіткого
розмежованого
навчання і буде друга типова освітня
програма яку можна застосовувати для тих
хто ще не навчився будувати авторські де
вона більше зорієнтована над предметне
навчання але вона теж буде
синхронізована по
темам в залежності від готовності
колективу і вчителів Ми дамо можливість
обирати ту чи іншу освітню програму Або
створювати власну Тому що це є
особливість академічної автономії школи
яку ми визначили у законі Про освіту Я
сподіваюсь що він до того часу буде
всетаки при Тепер нам потрібні
щонайменше 10 пілотних шкіл в Україні
які пропілотують в
2017-18 році ці
програми Я запрошую вас до співпраці
Якщо хочете стати такою пілотною школою
будь ласка ми дамо вам критерії за якими
ви можете себе перевірити чи ви готові
до запровадження та такого експерименту
вам Це треба буде узгодити з батьками у
ваших школах звичайно тому що ви їх
маєте поінформувати Що ви будете
працювати компетентнісним підходом і
будь ласка це будуть ті наші провідні
школи які будуть лаівками
реформи що ж робити з усіма решту
вчителями Ми плануємо всіх вчителів які
підуть до першого класу разом з своїми
дітьми в 18му-19му навчальному році
продити через систему підвищення
кваліфікації і зараз ми готуємо
модельний курс підвищення кваліфікації
для такого вчителя в рам компетентнісної
школи 25 000 вчителів наступного
навчального року пройдуть таку систему
підвищення кваліфікації ми готуємо
освітні матеріали для пілотування
е саме щодо першого класу і ці матеріали
будуть доступні для вчителів на
відкритій освітній
платформі Тобто можна буде побачити
це кожному вчителеві Незалежно від від
місця де він знаходиться будуть так
звані мультимедійні
додатки навчальні матеріали методики
викладання і вчитель зможе по-перше
підготуватися до уроку а по-друге разі
потреби Ми там закладаємо можливість
такого конструктора програми і
конструктора уроку де ви беручи різні
оці матеріали собі готуєте урок тому що
наше завдання яке ми бачимо Від
міністерства і в мене є два завдання Як
у міністра і в нашої команди яка працює
в міністерстві перше піднімати постійно
соціальний статус читилі і добивати всіх
політиків ее знаходити консенсус в уряді
щобими піднімали статус вчителів ми
зараз цей крок зробили підняли на два
тарифні розряди єдиної тарифної сітки
Працюємо з органами місцевого
самоврядування щоб вони платили всі
надбавки місто Київ попереду в цьому
плані Я дуже вдячна що вони це розуміють
всю відповідальність покладену на плечі
вчителів друге наше завдання забезпечити
вчителів адекватним
змістом це теж наше завдання Це
стандарти програми навчальні матеріали
це теж завдання Міністерства освіти і
науки але ми чекаємо в вчителів тепер ю
скроку намазус відкритості до реформи
бажання її зрозумі
бажання змінюватися і допомагати нам
проводити цю реформу в життя тому що все
залежить тільки від вчителів ми можемо
що хочеш написати викласти на відкриту
платформу розказувати заходить вчитель в
клас і там відбувається реальне шкільне
життя
е от рейтинг який був побудований
загальноосвітніх
шкіл 76 країн це зробила оні оці
економічної співпраці і розвитку ми не
брали участі в Пізі а вони робили саме
за пізою цей рейтинг але ми брали участь
у тімсі пам'ятаєте у 2008 році був тімс
так от вони транслювали результати тімсу
е в одну шкалу з пізою хоча це не зовсім
коректно бо вони перевіряють зовсім
різне teмс і Піза Але в цьому рейтингу
76 країн ми на 38му
міі ну це так
не дуже
Престиж і проблема наша полягає в тому
що ми з вами ще вчимо так як вчили в XX
столітті і думаємо що це забезпечить
дітям їхні можливості в XX столітті а
виклики є інші і З цим треба
змиритися ще один ще одна ознака нашої
школи що в нас невпинно погіршується
здоров'я дітий от
невпинно і ми мусимо знайти
компенсаторні е можливості самого
навчального процесу щоб так не
відбувалось
ці компенсаторні можливості інколи
виглядають зовсім примітивно але ми
навіть цього не робимо наприклад у
Фінляндії не тільки у Фінляндії в
Норвегії Я беру спеціально країни з
північним
[музика]
кліматом
діти проводять на
вулиці особливо в початковій школі і ті
які е віком до 12 років значно більше
навчального часу ніж у нас тобто вони
повинні провести зі своїм вчителем
принаймні один чи два уроки на
вулиці і це є загартування дітей
людей
щоденно тобто яким чином компенсувати
все що відбувається коли ми говоримо про
захворювання нервової системи що це є це
те що ми не розвиваємо емоційної
стійкості не розказуємо дітям як це
робити більше того самі не вміють цього
робити і над цим нам теж потрібно
попрацювати наша мрія завжди Ти повинен
чітко розуміти свою мрію щоб іти в
правильному напрямку от наша мрія оцей
випускник нової української школи який
буде насправді цілісною особистістю яка
здатна до критичного мислення який буде
патріотом з активною життєвою позицією
громадянином який здатний робити свій
вибір аргументувати своє рішення поважає
гідність і права кожної людини і цінує
власну гідність також і нам потрібен
інноватор інноватор який дійсно здатний
мислити інноваційно незважаючи від то
незважаючи на те в якій сфері життя
суспільство він буде працювати Тому що
інноваційність мисленні сьогодні буде
потрібна і гуманітарію і природничнику і
інженеру бо тільки так він може
конкурувати на ринку
праці
ми працюємо зараз з початковою школою ви
знаєте що ми дали рекомендації і
переглянули трохи
програму який ми отримуємо зворотній
зв'язок Шановні колеги
є ті хто імплементують ці рекомендації і
імплементують зміни до програми і
читають хрестоматію яку ми видали за
зекономлені кошти з текстами сучасних
дитячих українських письменників і діти
прекрасно знають і ці тексти і бачили цю
книжку книжка надійшла в усій в усі
шкільні бібліотеки
України але в нас є ціла низка шкіл де
діти навіть не бачили цієї крестоматії
бо вчителі просто не користуються нею на
урок і знаєте замінити червону ручку на
зелену щоб потім писати в щоденнику
Зеленим
кольором що ваша дитина неохайна не
слухняна і такасяка це нічого не змінює
до чого Я
веду проявіть нам треба проявити
лідерство кожен на свому місці і
пояснити що таке справжні
зміни і я звертаюсь до органів
управління освіти до інститутів
підвищення кваліфікації Потрібно
провести моніторинг яким чином
імплементуються оновлені навчальні
програми ми зараз Працюємо з
п'ятим-9в'ятим класом якщо з ним буде те
саме то ми знову ставимо дітей в нерівне
становище там де є вчитель який здатний
змінюватися який реагує на виклики часу
там це імплементується а там де є
байдужі люди які отримують таку ж
заробітну плату
іти в Ніякий спосіб не отримують бонусу
від праці проведеною величезною
кількістю провідних
учителів адже це неціло Міністерство і
десь на коліні собі написало якісь зміни
які придумала одна чи дві людини
безпрецедентне обговорення навчальних
програм відкрите на платформі Ера
залученням провідних вчителів країни які
мають величезний досвід мають досвід
успіху і невдач науковці яких ми
приєднали З академії педагогічних
наук різні люди які невайдужі до питань
освіти дітей працювали над цим залучені
були міжнародні
експерти так
от я тут написано Наші діти не можуть
чекати це як така
апеляція апеляція до кожного
вчителя так і до політиків які ніяк не
можуть в другому читанні розглянути
закон про
освіту Отже в 2016 оновлено програма ми
розуміємо що це косметичні зміни вони
косметичні але вони можуть дати певний
позитив для дітей якщо будуть
імплементовані
е-е 40 відео на платформі Ера для
вчителів початкової школи записано які
дають можливості подумати як працювати з
текстами як вчити дітей писати власні
тексти тобто є речі які є новими для
наших пересіч ну для пересічного вчителя
тому що я ще раз повторюю Е для мене
важливо для нас Важливо щоб
середньостатистичний учитель в Україні
оволодів такими методиками щоб це
перестало бути
ексклюзивом під який ми влаштовуємо
конкурси для частирічних дітей і беремо
благодійні
внески і показати які в нас
є яка в нас є вилка внесків так званих
доброчинних до українських шкілста 1000
грн сьогодні всі раді про це го
це не відповідає дійсності тому що
внески значно більше ніж 1000 грн буває
якщо первинно заходить в елітну школу
Яка фінансується з бюджету не
приватного то деяким батькам виставляють
значно більші Суми для заходу в перший
клас ну це вони говорили на 100 000 в
місяць додатково
найголовніше що ця ситуація є
неоднорідна і що ми робимо колеги ми
поглиблюємо нерівність в українській
освіті тому що є школи і батьки які не
можуть не можуть не не хочуть не можуть
нічого подібного і подібних сумдати і в
нас нерівність множиться вже в першому
класі для шестирічних дітей Ми ж
розуміємо що вибір цих дітей це є дуже
символічний це тільки підготовка робота
з диною до до співбесіди так от що ми
робимо ми по-перше з бюджету платимо
більше цим школам за поглиблене вивчення
одразу ставлячи дітей в іншій школі
загальноосвітній в нерівні умови з
першого класу а потім ще цю різницю
посилюємо батьківськими внесоми в дуже
різних
розмірах Я дуже сподіваюся що Фактор
того що бюджети місцеві отримали більше
грошей і можуть тепер більше вкладати в
освіту А також те що ми все-таки зробимо
вивчення іноземних мов
е обов'язковим і в більшому обсязі на
рівні початкової школи для всіх
дітей це трохи врівноважить і стере
оці величезні різниці хоча це перед нами
ставить море нових викликів починають
від вчителя іноземної мови який буде
працювати в початковій школі
[музика]
Гаразд тут хрестоматія я про це вже
сказала це як аналіз того що ми зробили
в минулому році але рухаємось
далі чому ми зараз переглядаємо п'ятий-
дев'ятий
клас тому що п'ятому-9вятому класі
залишилися всі ті самі проблеми які
характерні для нашої школи а базова ос
освіта є надзвичайно важлива з точки
зору формування
компетентностей і крім того є
залізобетонні що називається причини які
всім очевидні ви знаєте що в нас
порушені міжпреднеметні зв'язки якщо тут
є практики вчителі які працюють на рівні
базової школи ви знаєте приходиш на
фізику тобі треба застосовувати формулу
з математики яку ти ще взагалі на
математиці не
вчив вчителі зні бо якщо наприклад ще
вчитель історії України і всесвітньої
історії інколи це той сам вчитель і він
може якось дітям контексти пояснити то
там де вчителі предметники різні кожен
живе своїм життям як і зміст освіти з
цих предметів тому наша мета
ці порушення
забрати адекватно розмістити
зміст далі дуже мало завдань які спря
мовані на використання знань практичне
застосування в практичному житті і нам
важливо це звичайно питання підручників
які поки що не зміняться я ми тільки
дев'ятий клас друкуємо більше того нам
дуже важко впливати на видавців і на
якість підручників але це є окрема тема
але якщо вчителі будуть мати ці
матеріали які будуть розміщені на
онлайн-платформі і будуть мати до них
доступ вони зможуть їх теж застосовувати
бо підручник теж перестав вже бути
єдиним джерелом знань і єдиною
навчальною літературою і навчальним
матеріалом який може застосовувати
вчитель ігнорування вікових особливостей
дітей тут теж Всі розуміють велику
різницю між шостим клас п'ятим шостим
класом Це є одна група дітей і сьомим
восьмим дев'ятим - це зовсім інша група
дітей за старілі теми велика кількість
вимог ее одночасно велика кількість
засилля термінології термін які Дитина
просто потім може знайти і Не
обов'язково їх зазубрювати Але треба
пояснити яким чином
шукати Таким чином е це є це є одні
завдання очевидні але є ще завдання
розвиткові зараз зараз хвилиночку ту
трошки не в тому е порядку я не
бачу я не бачу цього слайду але він в
принципі тут мав бути іде мова про
запровадження
компетентності ясно що ми не можемо
зараз навалити в межах старого стандарту
і нав'язати запровадження всіх
компетентностей Але ми хочемо
попробувати
попрацювати принаймні через так звані
наскрізні теми обов'язкові для всіх
предметів щоб вчителі знали про
пріоритетні наскрізні теми і подаючи
свій матеріал для себе робили інспекцію
для себе власне як я можу це застосувати
під ці важливі пріоритетні теми для
програм п'ятого-9в'ятого класу в нас
обрано чотири пріоритетні теми і робочі
групи зараз теж працюють над тим які
навчальні матеріали можна
використовувати В яких предметах для
яких вікових е категорій дітей перша
тема актуальна для нашої країни це
безпека і безпека і здоров'я дітей як в
умовах війни
забезпечити власну безпеку безпеку своєї
родини своєї країни
і зберегти своє здоров'я друга наскрізна
тема присвячена громадянським
компетентностям тобто формуванням
відповідального
громадянина третя наскрізна тема
стосується підприємливості і фінансової
грамотності і ми дамо вам повний
викладемо повний набір матеріа лі
фінансової грамотності е ми взагалі-то
їх маємо з першого по 11-й клас
розроблені і в розрізі всіх
предметів і четверта тема стосується
ее сталого розвитку і функціонування
людини в
екосистемі ось чотири пріоритетні теми
наскрізні для всіх предметів на етапі
п'ятого-9в'ятого класу поки це ще не
новий стандарт А ми діємо з оновленими
програмами в межах е старого стандарту А
ось
знайшли Так так це хтось паралельно ще
ікає
Зіною можна так зробити за треба і
відкрити потрібний Зрозуміло А я думаю
що ж це він живе своїм життям так е
Шановні колеги це по п'ятому- дев'ятому
класі я ще готова буду відповісти також
на ваші питання хоча мало залишається ча
Старша школа
можу лише повернутися до статистики щоб
ви розуміли що інтенсивність обговорення
на еі пятих-9вятих класів дуже висока Я
вражена кількості талановитих вчителів в
цій
країні як раніше ми переглядали всі
програми працювала робоча група на базі
Національної академії педагогічних наук
або в Міністерстві освіти або в
інституті змісту модернізації змісту
освіти як правило там залучалися тільки
люди які мешкали у Києві тому що важко
збирати людей з усієї країни а зараз ці
цей відкритий підхід нам дав можливість
виявити і
залучити до активної участі талановитих
людей з усієї країни і це реально
примножило інтелектуальний потенціал
який ми можемо вкладати і в програми і
стандарти Старша школа ви знаєте що був
затверджений стандарт в 2011 році і цей
стандарт
передбачав відповідно кількість годин в
навчальному плані
е-е наприклад він
передбачав що
природничі природничі предмети в рамках
профільної старшої школи якщо це
гуманітарний профіль будуть вивчатися за
три години це не ми придумали
це визначив стандарт і в межах того
стандарту Міністерство освіти і науки
дало на обговорення навчальний план щоб
почути
реакції реакції тому що для мене було
очевидно що він неправильно
зроблений є прекрасна ідея зробити
старшу школу профільною це правильно Це
правильно тому що ми дітям в принципі
даємо основи знань до дев'ятого класу і
треба дати ї можливість старшу профільну
школу використати для того щоб вони
поглибили свої знання природу відповідно
за тими напрямками які вони обрали собі
для реалізації подальшої
житі красиво тільки проблема в тому що
профільну школу Ми хочемо внеснути в два
роки а вона би мала бути
трирічною І от звідси пішли оці перекоси
по кількості годин тому що ми не можемо
закрити для гуманітарія який сьогодні
думає що він
гуманітарій можливість вивчати
природничі предмети по-перше для
цілісної картини
світу по-друге може трапитись в його
житті Так в цьому динамічному
суспільстві і коли треба міняти а
сьогодні вже сьогодні в західних країнах
Європейського Союзу міняють професію по
три-чотири Рази за життя Що йому
прийдеться
перекваліфіковуватися І тому ми не
можемо звести це вивчення до
мінімум-мінімуму мору і е реакція пішла
правда пішла як негативне Міністерство
освіти яке Богу душу винно в цій
ситуації але нам ця реакція дала
можливість підняти це питання у
суспільстві і внести
[музика]
зміни Ми отримали більше 3 000
пропозицій до запропонованого
проекту що ми змінюємо у порівнянні з
тим що було опубліковано і ми це
представили на колегії Міністерства
освіти воно знайшло підтримку але ще не
схвалене до кінця обговорення
трива по-перше запровадження
інтегрованих предметів наприклад
природничі науки буде такий інтегрований
предмет в межах гуманітарного профілю
може здійснюватися мінімально з
обов'язковим обов'язковою кількістю
годин 4тири години плюс ви можете
добиратись годин за
видиро Я б хотіла підкреслити дуже
важливу думку з якої мабуть варто було
починати про 101-й
клас для нас кардинально важлива
автономія навчального закладу щоб він
сформував свій навчальний план
відповідно до профілю який він реалізує
бо не може бути
80% годин обов'язкових і при цьому вам
кажуть реалізуйте Проф
тобто ідея була так сконструювати
навчальний план щоб ви маючи свій
профіль який ви обрали могли самі
визначити що ви будете вивчати як
інтегрований курс він був такий
60% 40% - Це обов'язкові години ми їх
звели до мінімуму і 60% години заби
проблема в тому що дуже часто наші люди
розуміють що якщо це не внесено в
обов'язкові години То це
означає що це є стемі Ніхто більше не
буде додавати на цей
предмет Зараз ми в результаті цих
обговорень зробили
50х50 50 ми вписали в обов'язкові 50
будь ласка Обирайте ці 50 від 40 вийшли
за рахунок збільшення годин на
природничій предмет і так буде два
навчальні плани один навчальний план
який ми називаємо пілотним
і в цьому навчальному плані можуть
обирати інтегровані
курси наприклад природничі науки мінімум
4тири
години Але ми розуміємо що більшість
наших шкіл не готові до інтегрованого
навчання крім того є об'єктивна
реальність Ми сьогодні ще не маємо
програми цього інтегрованого курсу Ми не
маємо підручників до цього інтегрованого
курсу і ми не маємо готових
ми будемо працювати в 2017 18 році над
пілотуванням такого плану чи і програми
і Якщо хтось хоче пілотувати в себе в
закладі ми будемо вдячні за це
що в 2018 віддати Цю пропозицію на вибір
всім школам
України але вона має бути
підготовлена оскільки часу дуже мало ми
її називаємо пілотною вона не буде
обов'язковию наприклад інтегровані курси
не будуть
обов'язковими для того чи іншого профілю
тільки за бажанням
школи тобто є пілотний навчальний план з
інтегрованими курсами де ви конструюєте
навчальний план вашої школи Які курси ви
робите інтегрованими Що ви вивчаєте
поглиблено і скільки годин ви на що
дайте подивіться на цей Навчальний
план це є власне з пілотними
інтегрованими курсами У нас є кілька
пілотних інтегрованих курсів І взагалі
інтегрованих
курсів пілотними Ми назвали ті які
отримують більш найбільше запитань
це українська зарубіжна
література і природничі
науки значно менше питань і ми вже
досягли практично згоди з фахівцями і в
інтегрованому курсі
історії де історію України і історію
всесвітню інтегруємо в курс історія
України в контексті всесвітньої історії
цей інтегрований курс може
застосовуватися там де є профільними
природничі предмети і вам потрібні
години на природничі предмети і
громадянська освіта туди іде економіка
право це теж може бути інтегрований курс
чому ми досягли
консенсусу наших професійних
вчительських спільнот по наприклад курсу
історії і не досягли консенсусу по
курсах української зарубіжної літератури
і природничих
наук у вас є
версії відповіді на це
питання Як правило в школах історії
обидві читає один
учитель а в цьому випадку обох пілотних
курсів це різні
вчителі тому що предметне навчання воно
звичайно більшість кількість годин Тобто
ми рухаємося по Віль але от моє тверне
переконання що ті заклади які оберуть
пілотні план і потім покажуть
ефективність цих курсів тому що
наприклад інтегроване навчання
природничих наук в провідних системах
освітніх
світу можемо поскластися знову на ту ж
Фінляндію про яку так багато говорять
успіхів чи будь-яких інших в тих де є
Нобелівський
лауреат в тих де є серйозні наукові
школи
інтенатне навчання не поклало
ці
серйозні наукові школи і не знизило
якість природничої освіти Питання в тому
що ми туди покладемо які методи будуть
застосовані І найважливіше як зберегти
пізнавальну активність наших дітей і
бажання займатися природничими науками
щоб ви розуміли в рамках нашої чудової
предметної школи сьогодні природничий
профіль обирає 7% наших дітей сім
значить в нас щось не гаразд з
викладання природничих предметів і
залишати так як є категорично не можна
Отже це про те як позитивно ставляться
Ми хочемо щоб позитивно ставились
статистика поки що нам Це підтверджує
але Шановні колеги от я розумію що тут в
основному всі вчителі з міських
територій чому ми
думаємо над тим як швидко запроваджувати
трирічну старшу профільну
школу бо найбільша наша перешкода - це
на відсутність належної
мережі відсутність належної мережі тому
що наприклад сільській території Ви
повинні забезпечити цю профільність і
мати куди підвести дітей за їхнім
вибором такої мережі поки що не існує А
щоб ви розуміли з яким викликом ми
зустрічаємося в нашій країні і питання
рівності доступу до якісної освіти хочу
привести тільки
одну одні дані дивіться на цю табличку у
нас в сільських
територіях серед учнів 10тих класів - це
учні старшої школи яким здавати
ЗНО у школах в яких є менше ніж 10 дітей
навчається тут не видно цього рядочку
видно тут є понад
33%
дітей третина сільських дітей
акіло не мають доступу до якісної освіти
а понад 50% навчається в школах де менше
25 дітей
і тоді Розумієте це
ее у відповідь тим хто Розказує що
бачите в нас понижують ступіть школи і
буде вимирати
село діти сходять на
маніці діти
маргіналізуються тому що вони не можуть
здобути якісної освіти тому ми працюємо
зараз над так званими опорними школами
куди ми будемо підвозити дітей старшо
гараз
я просто не маю права Не залишити хоч
трохи часу на
запитання